you know before we bring out samuel
l.jackson I do want to mention something
sort of a behind-the-scenes little thing
focus we started doing this show 11
years ago we pretty much had the same
production offices a couple of floors
above this TV studio where we're
shooting right now and but recently NBC
decided to completely renovate our
offices and they made us move out so
they could demolish the whole place
demolish everything so they gave us like
a couple of days to sort of get
everything together and move out of the
offices and we actually shot some
footage to show you what's been going on
take a look well this is pretty
incredible I'm up here on our ninth
floor offices and they're gonna be
demolished
you're about 24 hours away from the
whole place being torn apart and
everyone is getting ready to move Blair
you all set yes you ready to move okay
this is it hey Dorf yeah you all set
they're gonna get rid of everything
walls floor everything okay everything's
gonna go people are packing up Weinberg
you all getting packed up okay because
they're gonna take everything it's all
gonna get torn down all cleared out
blitz you all set but any blitz on the
phone anyway everything's gonna go whole
place demolished it's pretty amazing
[Music]
well here I am at the ninth floor
offices and as you can see everything
has been completely demolished it's
pretty much an empty shell it's stunning
to see all the walls are gone the floors
had been ripped up the ceiling tiles all
the ducting everything completely why
when taken away and why did you walk
away when I was saying I Andy and I
wanted to return Andy
what she missed she misunderstood me
then he what what are you doing Andy
look look Andy look out here I said look
at this look at this look what's
happening at look at look at this place
they've torn everything out
ice no I said I didn't want
[Music]
price range